these satellite images show the angles
Air Base a strategic hub for Russian
forces before and after was hit by a
strike following the explosion there are
fewer aircraft left and what looks like
damage to the tarmac The Base is located
more than 350 miles away from the
Ukrainian border it's one of multiple
blasts that have recently hit military
bases and fuel storage sites in Russia
as well as Russian troops in Ukraine
including the deadliest known strike in
months the attacks highlight how combat
is not just playing out along the front
lines
targeted strikes like this one on
another Russian Air Base have taken on a
big role in the war
Aviation and Security Experts say the
images reveal Russia's struggled to
protect its military assets and
Ukraine's tactics to destabilize its
enemy
the engel's Airfield is the main
operating base of long-range aviation in
Russia
Engels has been used as a launch pad for
Russia's near daily or sometimes weekly
Air Raids across Ukraine in these
satellite images taken in early December
more than 30 Russian war planes can be
seen at the base that includes 19 tu-95s
strategic bombers capable of carrying
nuclear weapons
Aviation experts from Jane's an
intelligence firm and CNA a security
Think Tank analyzed the images
they said the planes are located closely
together without cover indicating they
aren't prepared for any type of strike
military and else imagine they must have
assumed that 350 miles into its own
territory was safe but shortly after a
first blast hit the base
the sound of the explosion was recorded
by security cameras nearby
Russia didn't immediately respond to a
request for comment about whether it was
prepared Moscow sent a statement that
Ukrainian drones were intercepted by its
air defenses and the wreckage hit the
facility killing three Russian
servicemen
Keith hasn't claimed responsibility for
the strikes but Ukraine's forces have
hinted that they're capable of launching
them
military analysts and images taken after
the explosion show it appears to be
firefighting foam underneath one bomber
and a possible impact site next to it
Days Later Moscow appeared to have taken
measures to try and protect its assets
on December 12th pictures show that nine
fewer tu-95 aircraft are at the base the
Ukrainian Ministry of Defense said the
planes have been relocated and Military
analysts say The Wider spacing between
the Plains and the newly erected
barriers are strategies to protect the
Hub from attacks Russia didn't
immediately respond to a request for
comment about those planes Weeks Later
another security camera captured the
sound of a second strike at the same
base
with its soldiers being hit by strikes
and military bases where they are
supposed to be relatively safe analysts
say Ukraine hopes to undermine the
morale of Russian troops this campaign
is also part of another front in the war
playing away far from the front lines in
Ukraine Russia has been shelling a
number of military and civilian
buildings and infrastructure but since
the early days of the war Kiev has been
working to show that it's also capable
of destabilizing the Invader in April
Ukraine hit the the flagship of the
Russian Black Sea Fleet the muskvah
sinking it which was the first big shock
the Ukraine could do this it also hit a
bridge that Putin open from Russia to
Crimea
several of those Ukrainian attacks
prompted Moscow to retaliate with heavy
barrages of missiles diverting attention
and resources from the front lines
strikes like this one on another
Airfield in Russia can also be hard to
detect complicating Russia's operations
Moscow accused Ukraine of hitting its
spaces with soviet-designed jet drones
that fly at a low altitude military
analysts point out it's difficult to
independently verify what weapons were
actually used and that makes it more
difficult for Russia to anticipate
future strikes on its own territory
Russia on its end also continues to use
missiles and drones to strike power
stations and other infrastructure in
Kiev and other parts of Ukraine causing
blackouts and disrupting life across the
country
but the strikes hitting its military
have affected operations and now that
base is closer to Moscow are being hit
military analysts say Russia is being
forced to spread out its already
stretched defenses